uh sir cliff if we can start
with you good to see you thank you very
much for being with us and this is a
campaign to change the law to provide
anonymity
just
give people watching a sense of the
impact you being named had on your life
well it could have destroyed me i
suppose because in fact it was such a
shock to
be sort of
suddenly wake up and find this has
happened especially seeing it on
television before i'd even known what
was happening at all
i found out later when i saw the tv show
afterwards that they'd broken into the
apartment and there'd been this
accusation
and i can't tell you it's hard to
describe when you're not guilty of
something
it's you just feel it's not true it
can't be true and then slowly as the
days go by you know the accusation was
made and it just it was um
the most horrible time and it took four
years before i absolutely completely
finished it and it wasn't until after i
had won my case with the bbc that i
actually felt this was the end of that
episode of my life
i'm past it
but uh i'll probably never get over it
it i i guess i've got it at least two or
three times a week maybe just in passing
sometimes but it's it's a it's a part of
my life that i'm thinking i didn't
deserve this i did nothing wrong and
somebody who did accuse me
will never will never know who he is
and once you were identified what did
you feel did you feel that you were
you know guilty in the court of public
opinion or guilty in the media that
there's no smoke without fire i mean
what was your you know your feeling
about that well that was the danger but
of course i thought to myself oh my some
people are going to believe this you
know i have to be strong when i went to
bed at night i knew that i was an
innocent my accuser must have known i
didn't do it
and god knew i didn't do it so i
survived thinking about those areas all
the time and the first thing i did
though that really relieved me i found
myself hating this person not knowing
who he was
and i remember waking up one night it
was always at 3 15 i don't know why 3 15
and i said
god i want to forgive him i don't know
how to do it but i'm just going to say
now i forgive this guy he probably has a
reason for doing it and as soon as i
released that i found myself more
not exactly comfortable but it became a
little bit easier to decide i didn't
think i could go on hating someone like
this it was really that was bad for me
and so to get it off my chest i just
forgave him and the thing is of course
unless he's watching this show um he
probably never knows that i forgave him
and paul you spent a year on bail i
think uh before your case was dropped
what what was life like for you during
that time
it
was a
completely different existence from what
i had lived before
and
since i have lived after that
because what it was was that i was
shunned
from many organizations which i helped
to found or fund
and also of course uh i was immediately
dropped
by the bbc from working so i lost about
100 000 pounds in earnings at exactly
the moment when i needed money to pay
legal bills so it got a bit tense
but fortunately i had a very loyal and
supportive husband christopher and my
close friends stayed with me my family
in america stayed with me
and we just had to see it through we
just had to survive it
get up every day as nigel evans who was
also falsely accused said every morning
you woke up and it was like being hit by
the same truck
uh for about two seconds you would not
realize that this was happening and then
it would hit you
and i was really glad and i'm going to
say this
that i was able to be of help to cliff
because i
went first
and then our cases overlapped and then
mine was over and his kept going until
it ended
and a couple of times he would say to me
i'm experiencing this what does it mean
and you'll remember the one time when
you said to me i'm afraid i'm losing my
mind because i was talking to myself you
know and i said no you're a professional
and you're rehearsing in case you ever
had to go before a joke and you thought
oh yeah i'm rehearsing
uh and uh
then when i
thankfully was able to
lead the effort for a law reform which
was the bail reform you said to me
i'm inspired you've had a law reform i
want a law reform and what i want is
anonymity before charge right and um and
so daniel your father was caught up in
sexual abuse allegations that were never
tested i think i'm right in saying in
court um because of illness and
so forth um why do you think it's so
important that this should be enshrined
in law now well
his case was a classic case because the
leicester police
advertised the fact of his uh flat being
searched the papers put in photographs
and it was like fly paper to false
accusers to come forward and make false
allegations which they were and in his
case it was about civil uh proceedings
and
he was sued and then the estate was sued
and every single one of those civil
actions collapsed because it was total
rubbish
and we as a family and he would never
have gone through the agony that he did
if the law was as we are proposing and
what we are proposing is a fairness a
balance
so that the complainant rightly has
anonymity
as it happens for life we're saying that
the innocent suspect or the person who
may well be innocent for that matter has
protection
until such time as he or she is charged
and that strikes us as being the fair
balance and we had a meeting stay in the
house of lords
a number of very important
parliamentarians were there so cliff
spoke abusively as did paul
and i think they were um persuaded and i
think we're going to get this
legislation through it's a small change
it's a fair change and it should happen
right so cliff i mean is the plan that
this law applies to not only the police
but to journalists and to to everyone in
a way
um i just wonder how realistic you think
it is with social media you know a
famous person is arrested or their home
is searched by dozens of police someone
somewhere
is going to have a camera and is going
to put it on social media is it is it
realistic
this anonymity i just wonder
if we get what we want and look it's a
compromise
um you know i i don't know what happened
to king john at magna carta who changed
the rules he said that every single one
of us in this nation is innocent unless
proven guilty in a court of law
and so suddenly we're having to face the
fact that although your name can be
plastered all over the place it took i
asked a friend of mine how long do you
think it took to get to all the
countries i've been to from new zealand
australia southeast asia all over europe
she said my dear
about 10 seconds
and i'm thinking oh my so and i had to
deal with the fact that many people
would have perhaps thought there was no
smoke without fire and yet as a rock
star i know there's no smoke without
fire we don't need a fire to make smoke
on stage so it was one of those things
that was frustrating for me
and so therefore
you know
if we could trust the media completely
in 100 percent
normally for instance now we're on
television
people who are watching are listening to
what we say
you can't edit it it's going out live
i love that sometimes you can do an
interview and they'll leave out a comma
or a footstep a full full stop and it
sounds like you've said something else
so i think that a law
would force them to say
we're not allowed to name him until he
or she is charged and that makes sense
to me once you're charged it means the
police think they have enough evidence
to take you to court now in court
you could be found innocent or you could
be found guilty can i can i make a
couple of points can i just ask you a
question maybe because yeah i'm
interested because the is there ever
daniel or paul
is there ever a legitimate policing
reason for
naming suspects because
the police you know have this guy they
would argue that you know in some cases
it would encourage other complainants
not victims as you say complainants to
come forward to make their case so is
there ever a case
um and that's just what i wanted to come
in and say because within this proposal
within this proposed legislation
is a provision for a the police
or the press for that matter in certain
cases such as a war boys case by way of
example to have the restriction lifted
in certain restricted circumstances
can i just at one point well this
campaign is not only about uh the
well-known people this whole campaign is
about uh protection for everybody
because i suppose some people would say
well look there's a public interest
argument paul that you know there's a
transparency argument is that at all a
factor do you think or do you think your
rights or to whoever's right to
anonymity
um
over weighs or outweighs that you know
the the the um the stigmatization
well the basic tenets of british justice
innocent until proven guilty
uh it
shows us that you should not be assumed
to be guilty uh and particularly uh
until the cps believes there's a better
than 50
chance of your conviction in which case
you become charged
now it's very important that there is
this element in the bill which daniel
has mentioned which is that if a jojo
magistrate believes that the suspect is
a threat in the current moment as john
warboys was then that person can be
named
but in most cases where the accusation
concerned something that happened years
ago there's no rush if you believe the
police are professional give them the
chance to do their job to build a case
until a charge is justified
this is an area where the spectrum runs
from 100 accurate accusations to 100
percent false accusations and we have to
be able to hold more than one idea in
our head at the same time
many genuine victims of abuse want to
come forward or should feel the
confidence to come forward but
we also must acknowledge
many accusations are false either
because the person is what i politely
call distressed or is a fantasist or has
a grudge
and
for those who wish that everybody could
come forward and name names i have to
say i've studied all these cases and
i've discovered that many of the people
who come forward are for some reason or
not not speaking truth and i can say
this let me just say that before you ask
your next question
the idea of the public's interest
i don't think it was in the public
interest to have a helicopter outside my
apartment showing the police rummaging
around my underwear and stuff
i don't think that works it doesn't work
so that's not an argument that we need
to deal with i don't think and also i
read in the newspaper once that the
people are very interested on david
what's his name the footballer his
underwear color but should they know the
color of his underwear
no
so look just finally sir cliff you
suggested at the beginning that this you
know
harmed your mental health basically
quite severely i mean how bad did it get
it got i was never suicidal but there
were a number of times when i would wake
up and funnily enough for some reason it
was always 3 15 when i woke up and it
was most nights and sometimes i'd wake
up with every pulse in my body thumping
and i didn't feel suicidal at all but i
kept waking up thinking oh my god i'm
going to die of a heart attack
and it could only have been bro that's
just that position in my
bed like that could only have been
brought on
by knowing that i was totally innocent
and yet being dragged through
all the
papers although the papers were
generally very much in my favor the bbc
should never have done that they should
never ever have done that